[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE DIAMOND: Welcome, everyone.
And thank you all for
coming to today's talk.
My name is Mike Diamond, and
I'm a manager in the Google
Advertiser Platforms
Division, focusing
on programmatic strategy.
And I'm really
excited and honored
to be moderating today's talk.
I've been a member of
the leadership council
for an organization
called Upwardly Global
for the past nine or so years.
The organization helps
refugees and immigrants
find meaningful work
in the US that's
requisite with their
skills and experience.
And when I think
about when I first
got involved with
the organization,
it's amazing, because there
was really very little coverage
of refugees and immigrants.
It took me a matter
of 5, 10 minutes
to truly explain the
organization's mission.
But over the past year, with
the deluge of media attention,
there's been an increasing focus
on refugees and immigrants,
not only in the US,
but around the world.
And it's been quite a tumultuous
time for both of those groups.
And refugees, in
particular, have
been in the spotlight,
both here and abroad,
and for good reason.
Worldwide displacement is
an absolute all-time high
with, simply, record numbers.
They're staggering.
One in nearly every 122
people around the globe
is either a refugee, internally
displaced, or seeking asylum.
65 and 1/2 million people
have been forcibly displaced,
which is a 60% increase
from just a decade ago.
And over 22 million
of those are refugees.
So today, we welcome
two guests who
can help us better
contextualize and understand
emerging stories in the media,
as well as our country's
rhetoric and policies
towards newcomers, really,
new Americans.
Our discussion today is going
to be focused on both refugees
and immigrants-- really who they
are, the workforce issues that
surround them, and our
country's policies towards them.
We're going to hope to cover
US policy, as well as practices
with regards to resettlement of
both refugees and immigrants.
We'll talk about the differences
between refugees, asylum
seekers, migrants,
and immigrants,
as we often don't
talk about the nuance
between those different groups
and finally, talk about some
of the support systems that
are here in America to support
these communities.
So without further ado,
let me introduce you
to our two guests.
First, Sussan Khozouri is the
Senior Director of Philanthropy
and Partnerships at the American
Jewish Joint Distribution
Committee, also
known as the JDC.
She's had over 25 years
of experience working
in the refugee
humanitarian field
and, in the course
of her career,
has worked for three of the nine
resettlement agencies in the US
in managing various aspects of
their resettlement programs.
She attended Wellesley College
and also received her degree
from the Fletcher School
of Law and Diplomacy
at Tufts University.
Sitting next to me
is Nikki Cicerani,
who I've known for
many years and is
the CEO of Upwardly
Global, where she's worked
for the past eight-plus years.
As we'll hear
later, Up-Glo's work
grew out of the
resettlement system
and is the first and
longest-serving organization
to support the integration of
skilled refugees and immigrants
into the US workforce.
Nikki has received
her MBA from Columbia
and has a bachelor's degree in
policy analysis from Cornell.
So to kick things off, I'd like
to just baseline a little bit
on resettlement as
a topic, in general.
I'm going to turn to Sussan.
I would love you to help us get
an understanding of the refugee
situation, both globally,
and here in the US,
and start to understand
why displacement
has grown so much over the past,
particularly, 10 years or so.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: OK.
Hello, everybody.
So I'll focus on
resettlement in the US.
But just for perspective, the
situation right now in Syria
is definitely the thing
that has turned the pendulum
and really ramped up the
desperation and the situation
for refugees worldwide.
But really, we live in
a world where there's
much less peace building.
There's so much more
persecution than ever before.
But also, we don't
address the root causes
so that people can go back.
I mean, many of us remember
situations in Vietnam,
in Bosnia, in Rwanda
where refugees
returned to their homes.
There is less and
less of that today.
So today, we still see
millions of refugees
that have left Afghanistan.
How many of you even remember
when Afghanistan happened?
That was way back in the 1980s.
Some of you weren't even born.
Sudan, Somalia--
all these things--
these refugee crises
were so protracted,
and we haven't dealt with the
peace building side of it.
And so refugees are
just basically--
some of my colleagues
call it "warehoused"--
in refugee camps or in
cities around the world,
in poor countries, and
neighboring countries,
and that's just
persisted for so long.
So there's been a build up, but
very few solutions at the root
causes.
Very few refugees are resettled.
So of the numbers you
mentioned, Mike, maybe 1% only
get resettled.
And it's like a
lottery in a sense.
If you get out of
your country and have
a chance at third-country
resettlement, many refugees--
most of them, the bulk of them--
are in neighboring countries
where, really, it's
hard to welcome them
because the neighboring
countries are poor.
And it's just such
millions and millions
of people who need
jobs, need livelihoods,
need food, clothing, et cetera.
And refugees don't want to
be recipients of welfare.
They want to be able to
have a chance at continuing
their lives.
That's why organizations
like yours are so important,
but all of our work
is so important.
So in the US, the US
Resettlement Program
traditionally has been
different than other countries
because our focus is employment,
almost to our detriment.
So the agencies-- there's
nine resettlement agencies
in America.
There were more before
the fall of communism,
but now there's nine.
Most of them are faith-based,
and three of them are not.
So their Church World Service,
Hebrew Immigrant Aid Society,
Lutheran Immigration Refugee
Services, US Catholic
Conference, World Relief--
the evangelical group.
They don't proselytize.
But the reason
they're important is
that there are churches
and constituents
all over the country
that welcome refugees.
And the other three that
are nondenominational
are the International
Rescue Committee,
US Conference for Refugees, and
there is an Ethiopian group--
Ethiopian Community
and Development group
that does the same work--
committee.
So all of them have sponsors
around the country that
help with the resettlement.
So they have professional
staff and sponsor.
Because the resettlement
program in America
is a private-public partnership.
The idea is, it's so
important to welcome refugees
in your community.
And you don't want to impact any
one community in the country.
Usually, if refugees
had their choices,
they'd all go to
Florida, California--
because they're warm
in their minds--
and maybe New York
because it's so receptive.
But welfare is such, in
some of these states,
that it's so generous that,
really, the system is geared
in such a way that refugees
who don't have family members
usually have to go to
states where they have
hospitable communities
to welcome them
and to work with a professional
staff like these nine agencies.
And what we're
responsible for doing
is refugees are recognized as
refugees by state departments
overseas.
It's asylum seekers that
come to the US borders,
but refugees are recognized.
It's part of the
US foreign policy
to recognize people of
humanitarian concern to the US.
So it's usually countries
that America realizes
are persecuting its
own populations.
The President of the
United States and Congress
set the ceilings, the numbers
of people who get to come in.
And basically, they're
processed overseas.
It's a long, long, long process.
All of you have heard that
screening people for admissions
to the US is very
complicated because you
have to go through a lot
of security clearances.
Basically, you go through a
UN agency called the UN High
Commissioner for Refugees,
who, then, refers you
for resettlement to one of
many countries in the world.
Your papers go through.
Some refugees have
been there 10, 20,
30 years before they
even arrive to America,
especially those
coming in from Africa.
Some come in about
two, three years,
which is considered
very fast after waiting.
And they come here.
We receive them.
The resettlement agencies,
basically, receive them
with sponsors in America.
The responsibilities
are to get people
employed as soon as possible.
And for that
reason, they usually
take very low-paying jobs.
The bar is to try and get jobs
that will help people become
self-sufficient--
enough money to
pay for your rent.
And basically, over
a longer time frame--
a longer arc in your life--
you start learning
the English, you
start doing all
those other things,
and you slowly, slowly
move up the ladder.
So it's a difficult
thing, but that's
the emphasis of the US program.
In some of the
countries in Europe,
they would rather a
refugee go on welfare
than get the job
of a local person.
But in the States, that's
not the way we do it.
We do it with a real emphasis
on early self-sufficiency.
And so when refugees come in,
the resettlement agencies,
within 90 to 120 days,
have to get you a job,
help you with an apartment.
And remember, it's not just
through state department money,
it's a lot of the goodwill of
American people and neighbors
and communities.
Get you jobs, social
security numbers,
help enroll kids in school, help
connect you to your community
because nobody wants refugees
to live in isolation.
You both want a host
community and a community
that might be existing--
like an ethnic community that
can speak the same language so
they can have access to food
that's familiar to them.
So basically, the program
runs, for the most part,
really beautifully, but with
the idea that you give people
the minimum.
Over the long term, there
are other social services
that refugees can access--
state employment programs,
ESL programs, et cetera.
And that goes on
for a long time.
But it takes organizations
like Upwardly Global
that have that specific
understanding of what
kind of support system somebody
trying to get a new job
and move up in the
market really requires.
And so organizations
like this are
more and more important to
make sure that refugees are not
an underclass.
Because as Mike said,
they're new Americans.
They are not refugees
when they arrive here.
We've selected them
as people who will
be part of our communities.
And many, many
contribute immediately.
Sorry it was a long, long
response, but it's a big issue.
MIKE DIAMOND: Can you
tell us a little bit more
about the profile of refugees?
So are they families,
Individuals--
what does that look like?
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: OK.
So in general, it's a
difficult question to answer.
The UN High Commissioner
for Refugees
used to have these posters and
says, "These are Refugees."
And there would be
these little puppets--
pictures of anybody
you can imagine.
So because, basically, when
you have a refugee crisis,
it's everybody.
So it could be anyone
who's a Muslim, anyone
who's a Christian, anyone who's
a Jew, and from all classes.
It doesn't discriminate.
Governments don't
discriminate just by class.
So it's basically everyone.
More than half are
probably children.
Most coming to the
US are families.
There are situations and places
where single people are coming
primarily because of,
maybe, specific persecution
that a government has
inflicted on a certain group.
But generally, it's
mostly families.
But it's everybody.
It's carpenters, it's
journalists, it's everybody.
It's anybody.
MIKE DIAMOND: You
started mentioning--
I know you've
worked for a number
of the resettlement
organizations.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the process
that those organizations go
through to help families,
to help individuals?
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: OK.
So most important is
having volunteers--
having people to
support refugees.
That's one of the
most important things.
We usually rely-- so
again, another aspect
of the American program,
vis a vis refugees,
is priority is
given to people who
have family members in the
US, because they're obviously
the biggest support system.
And then your community
and volunteers
are the other support system.
So for church-based
organizations,
you can have many churches
helping with sponsorship--
so mentoring kids in
school, mentoring families,
helping families-- there's
a lot of psychosocial issues
that maybe people are
suffering from-- isolation,
depression-- so it really
helps to be integrated.
The church-based agencies
I've worked for often
have used church sponsors
or community connections.
But a church agency will
also work with a mosque
if you bring in a lot
of interfaith groups.
Because you don't want people
to just be labeled and just
be ghettoized when they come.
It's really so important.
As many more people as you can
bring in, the more important
it is.
And maybe the single
most important aspect
is financial, which is
helping people get jobs,
helping women with, maybe,
five children find childcare.
So they really-- the agencies
help with all of that very much
in the beginning.
The expectations of the
organizations are all the same.
So whether I worked for
a church-based agency
or the International
Rescue Committee,
the basic fact is,
we all have to give
a certain standard of
service to make sure
that people are
self-sufficient or know
where to go and get services
so they're not on their own.
Because there are a lot of
support systems from the state
that also are
available to people.
MIKE DIAMOND: And just a quick
follow-up-- how long do those
support systems last?
Does it differ?
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: So
it's very short in terms
of the contract with which,
let's say, the resettlement
agencies have with
state departments.
So it's between 90 to 120 days
that the relationship really
is there.
And then the rest of it
is referrals and passing
things on to state and city
actors or private actors
like Upwardly Global who come
in, and help out, and pick
people up to the next
step and next level.
And some of the organizations
have longer-term contracts.
They may have employment
contracts from the state
or from the city.
Because there is an
understanding by many states
and cities that you require a
specific kind of understanding
and language
experience and cultural
experience to help
with these things.
MIKE DIAMOND: In
your experience,
what do you think some
of the biggest challenges
that the organizations
face as they're trying
to help some of these groups?
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: OK.
So today-- and I bet everyone
would have the same response
is--
it's just this feeling
of fear and feeling
that you're not welcome.
I should also tell
you that refugees,
when they're fleeing
their countries,
very often don't want to
go to a Western country.
And most people think they do.
No.
They want to be
right by their homes
so they can go
back home tomorrow.
And the fact is, after
10, 20 years, 5 years,
you stop thinking that, even
with the Syrian refugees.
It was very, very difficult
for the Western world
to convince them that you
have been so persecuted,
you are unlikely
to go back home.
You know, resettlement might
be the right thing for you.
You have a chance at a new life.
And most people make those
decisions for their children
because they know that
going back is not an option.
So the challenges, to me,
are isolating people, fear,
which is part of what's
happening in today's rhetoric
about refugees.
I mean, the idea that you
can have a bag of Skittles
and one of them can
be dangerous is--
that creates fear.
And that's not been
the history of America.
So we talk about refugees,
but in America, there
have been so many groups that
have come in for hundreds
and hundreds of years.
Even before there was an
official enactment of refugee
law, we've had
immigrants and refugees
coming since this
country started.
And there's been backlash--
backlash against the Chinese,
backlash against the Irish
backlash against the Italians--
I mean, hatred and vitriol
like we hear today--
so actually, I'm very positive.
I feel this is part of a
trend that will change.
But I feel that there are
moments in our history
that this happens.
But I really believe, and
what I've seen everywhere,
is there is something
unbelievable in America
in terms of how America
welcomes the stranger because so
many Americans have had
the experience of being
a stranger themselves,
and it's unbelievable.
So many of us and
our family members
have been recipients of
that kind of kindness.
MIKE DIAMOND: It's nice to
hear some of that optimism.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: Yeah.
I believe that genuinely.
MIKE DIAMOND: One of the
things that's really struck me
through my experience
with Upward Global was
how many refugees and
immigrants are highly educated
and are coming to this
country with years
and years of experience
and university degrees.
A stat that I've learned is,
roughly 28% of that community
has bachelor's
degrees or higher,
which is compared to roughly
29% of the US population.
The interesting thing is
that, despite that expertise,
despite that experience,
so many of these immigrants
and refugees are
either unemployed
or, as Sussan alluded,
are underemployed,
which is a term we don't
really talk about a lot.
And so many of them
end up being very poor,
and that is certainly not a
situation that they deserve.
And so when I think
about Upwardly Global--
I want to kind of
transition over to Nikki
to talk about why
that problem exists,
and how do you think
you've addressed it,
and how can other organizations
kind of address it?
NIKKI CICERANI: Sure, sure.
So I think it's easiest to talk
about the founding of Upwardly
Global because our founder--
and I'm not the founder
of the organization--
was working in
refugee resettlement.
And while resettlement
happens through nine
different volunteer agencies
throughout the country,
the government also has
some national services
that help all of those volunteer
agencies do their jobs,
particularly with respect to,
as Sussan said, employment.
Our founder was working in that
employment technical assistance
to the volunteer agencies when
the first wave of Bosnians
came over.
Now the Bosnian refugee cohort
was relatively highly educated.
And it was in seeing that
the system was set up
to do, what Sussan said,
rapid-attachment jobs.
Those jobs tended to be
low wage, low skill work.
And it was her experience
watching, literally,
surgeons and engineers wind up
in the front lines of chicken
processing plants where they
were considered the best
employees in the organization,
but there was nothing left
in the system to help them get
back into their trained fields.
And our founder was sort
of spinning the narrative
on its head, which
is, not only is it
an old, romanticized narrative
that the first generation comes
and sacrifices so that the
next generation can enjoy
the opportunities
of this country,
and that that's a detriment
to the individual,
but that that's also a
detriment to the country.
So this was really at
the beginning in which--
I mean, we've talked
more and more-- certainly
over the last decade
when I've been
with Upwardly Global-- about
a skills gap in the country.
But the vision of our
founder was exactly that.
We're losing out on two sides
when we accept underemployment
and when the narrative
we build is encouraging
those who are coming
with skills to accept
their new station in life.
And that was part of what
happened in the system,
that there was a bit of
a narrative that says,
look, your education
from your home country
may just not count here.
Or the quicker you accept
your new station in life,
the better your
integration is going to go.
And Upwardly Global was
founded for that niche
of the population
where we were trying
to change that
narrative by proving
that better outcomes were
possible for refugees and then,
as we grew as an
organization, realizing
that the problem existed
for a much broader swath
of the immigrant population.
So we exist because--
despite the media
having you believe
that every immigrant in the
country might be undocumented
or coming through
the H1B process,
most people don't know--
we legally allow
about a million people
into the country every year
through our regular immigration
channels.
And so our primary immigration
policy in the country
is family reunification.
We also, of course, have a
policy of refugee resettlement,
where you're getting a skilled
population coming through,
and then also, the
diversity card lottery.
So through those
three channels alone,
you get a million
people coming in a year.
And of the adult population
of that larger group,
you've got 48% who have
a bachelor's or better,
and you have drastic
underemployment.
So on the whole, if you look at
everybody coming in, about one
in four wind up
under or unemployed.
And then, if you look at
subgroups like refugees, those
coming from Africa,
Latin America,
Middle East-- it's much
more drastic than that.
Why does that happen?
So if you start to think
about your own trajectory
as a professional, and you start
to think about what you needed
in order to get where you're
going, some of those things
will not be there for
somebody coming to the country
after they've been educated
and started their career.
So the biggest thing that could
possibly be missing, of course,
is English language skills.
And that's true for
about half the population
that wind up under or unemployed
is that their English is simply
not sufficient.
Now, that doesn't mean
that they're not fluent.
It means that, actually,
there's a big difference
between being good at English
and what they call very good.
And I promise you, these
are technical terms.
Good is where you can
actually be very conversant.
Somebody understands
what you need,
understands how to give
it to you because you
can make yourself understood.
Being very good actually
transgresses that,
and it means you've actually
achieved a level of English
where you're as likely
to speak it in the home
as you are your home
country language.
And it also means
that you understand
the contextualized
English of your field.
And so when you have
English barriers,
I don't want everybody to
think that you have people
who don't speak English at all.
That part of the problem is that
English is not moving people
from that good to very good.
In addition to that, one
of the biggest barriers
that newcomers face is a lack
of a professional network.
Think about how you found
your job here at Google.
It could be that a recruiter saw
you on LinkedIn and called you.
It could be that they found
that profile on LinkedIn
through somebody else they
were looking at on LinkedIn.
But in most cases, as we
progress through our careers,
we use our network to find
our next job or an opening
in that job.
When you come
through resettlement,
when you come through
family reunification,
you are less likely to have
that professional network.
And then, there's
other barriers.
Acculturation--
the job search is
very different here
in the US than it
may be in other countries.
So a very classic example--
I don't know if we have anybody
who's educated outside the US,
experience outside the US--
but your résumé may have its
picture on it, marital
status, religious affiliation.
It's not atypical to
have a five, six, seven,
even eight-page résumé from
certain parts of the world.
And then, if you just start
to think about the nuance
of American culture--
we are typically self-promoting,
meaning that we don't shy away
from talking about
accomplishments of yourself
or your team--
but that you have
to actually do that.
We express enthusiasm
about a job.
We tend not to be as
hierarchical as other cultures.
So our interview
processes require
that we ask the interviewer
questions-- things that
may feel odd coming from
other types of cultures
where that's just not
done in the job search.
And so what you have
is this no network,
résumé and a set of job search
skills that are not working
here, and then,
finally what you have,
is you have a misunderstanding
of foreign education.
Foreign degrees just
simply, in most cases,
is not as highly prized and/or
understood as a US degree.
And so when you're coming
with a Middle Eastern name
and the University of
Baghdad on your resume,
an employer may see
that and simply not know
what to do with it.
And that's the kind
of innocuous version.
And then the non-innocuous
one is subconscious and even
conscious bias.
We're here in New York City.
Sometimes it's hard for us to
really grasp that that happens.
But I can tell you, we work
throughout the country,
Upwardly Global, and we
see, routinely, simply
bias in the hiring process.
So that's why the problem
exists and who it exists for.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: The
refugees in America
are resettled in some 300
communities across the country.
So you can imagine where
some of this plays out.
MIKE DIAMOND: So one of
the interesting things is,
there's been a big focus in
previous administrations,
particularly Obama
administration,
around economic opportunity
and placing refugees
into their fields--
a program called
Partnership for Refugees.
With nearly 6 million
open jobs in the country,
why do you think--
what are some more
of the reasons why
you feel like it's so difficult
for refugees to get placed,
both on the--
well, we've talked a lot
about the refugee side,
but even more so, potentially,
on the corporate side,
from your experience working
with some of the biggest
companies?
NIKKI CICERANI: So yeah.
So just to sort of juxtapose--
the Obama administration
was very interested in immigrant
integration in the workforce.
And so there was a
larger effort, broadly,
for immigrants and
then, very specifically,
to bring companies to
the refugee crisis--
a corporate response called
Partnership for Refugees.
I think, largely,
companies don't necessarily
find this population as readily,
particularly the refugees,
for a number of reasons.
One is, they tend to have a
gap at the top of their resume.
It could be a handful of months.
It could be a number of years.
And so if their most recent
job is actually stocking shoes
at Payless when, in fact, they
are an engineer of some sort--
and we see all kinds--
it's unlikely that somebody
reviewing a résumé pool is
going to understand
why that gap exists.
And we may make certain
assumptions about that gap.
And simply, we're in
competitive markets, right?
How do we screen
lots of résumés?
The second is, again, I think
a very large misunderstanding
about the work authorization
of certain immigrant classes.
Refugees have a green card.
They work without
visa sponsorship,
as do a number of
immigrant classes.
So I can't tell you
how many times we've
worked with big companies,
Fortune 15 companies, that
have said to me, we
can only hire citizens.
And I have to
delicately say, that's
actually an EEO violation.
Unless the position requires
security clearance where
citizenship is necessary, for
most positions in the economy,
you're not allowed
to discriminate
between a green card
and citizenship.
And so the
misunderstanding when they
see a foreign name
and a foreign degree
is that this person
will need sponsorship,
and we don't do that.
And then the other thing
is, where are the channels?
Where are our companies
going for their talent?
So you work within networks.
I'm sure, even here
at Google, right,
there's a strong
referral culture--
refer your friends-- if
you're smart and motivated.
And they're coming again.
So what helps refugees
in the beginning
are ethnic enclaves--
that support them
in language acquisition,
getting their kids in school,
ethnic groceries--
can also become
isolating when they're not
connected to the mainstream.
And so you do find this
gap between where they are
and companies saying
that they want talent,
but not necessarily knowing
where and how and how
to evaluate within the
existing processes,
the talent pool that lies
within these 2 million highly
skilled, but
underemployed, immigrants
and refugees in the country.
MIKE DIAMOND: So I
guess, as a follow-up
to that, what are some of the
ways in which, at a policy
level, we're educating
corporate leaders to be
able to understand
those groups better?
NIKKI CICERANI: Right.
I think the larger
conversation right now is
about finding talent, period.
So I think you see
a couple of things.
I think you see
a larger movement
to understanding that
diversity and inclusion happens
in a lot of ways, that
we have to source talent
from a lot of venues.
And in addition to that,
it's, I think, really
about companies embracing bias
as we see them trying to do
and really understanding
where they may have that bias.
And then I think it's really
about understanding recruiting
processes, and how often are
we really creating diversity
through our processes
versus screening it out.
But from a policy
standpoint, it's
still at an individual
company level.
This administration
has not sought
to catalyze the corporate
sector in, maybe,
the same way that the
last administration did.
And so it's still at a very
individual company level.
I think it's still under the
broader umbrella of companies
seeking talent and
being in a moment
where, how do you assess that?
Could it come from
foreign degrees?
Can it come from no degree?
And we're seeing
this broader idea
that maybe we don't need
a degree for certain jobs
in the economy, and
we're just inflating
what is necessary in
educational attainment
to achieve certain
in-demand jobs.
So I think that we're just
trying to thread ourselves
and the population into
the larger narrative
right now about where
talent is and how
we access it-- the things
we have to do to get at it.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: I
would just say that,
at a really basic level, the
fear that's going on right
now-- this vilifying
immigrant communities,
this sense that
they're pariahs--
rather than looking
at people as assets--
bringing in assets, bringing in
degrees, bringing in diversity,
bringing in diversity
in ethnicity,
but bringing in
diversity even in age.
You know, America has
been very, very lucky
because we're a
young country because
of this influx of a million
new people every year.
We're not Japan.
We're not Italy.
We're not suffering
from a workforce
to retirement ratio
like other countries.
Because of this, there
are so many-- and in many,
many places--
I don't know where
you are all from,
but there are many
cities in America
that can talk about
being revitalized because
of new ethnic communities that
have come in, and are working,
and have brought work, and have
invested in private businesses.
And so all of that's not
part of the conversation now.
And really, I hear,
even from people--
I met recently with a couple
of people who are from Google
and whose husbands and
wives don't have jobs.
But people are afraid to go
out now and look for jobs.
Everyone is so afraid
of discrimination.
NIKKI CICERANI: I'm not going
to overstate this statistic,
understanding that
I'm at Google.
But we did start to
track-- we partner
with employers in our program.
Our program focuses
largely on the soft skills
that immigrants need--
job search skills, resume,
interviewing, networking.
And we've made those things
such that they can do them
in a self-paced way or that they
can have one-on-one advisory
through our program.
And then on the employer
side, we engage employers.
We do training for them
on who the population is,
we do some anti-bias training.
But we also engage employers
in volunteer opportunities.
We've done it with Google
where employees actually
work as mock interviewers
to newcomers,
and they teach
them, really, what
was good in the interview,
what wasn't, they
get formalized feedback, it goes
into their advisory process.
But we do also believe
in contact theory.
And even in these
major markets--
Upwardly Global has a
footprint of about seven cities
throughout the US--
some like New York
and some like Boise, Idaho.
And what's incredible is
that, uniformly across that,
contact theory holds--
that people will change their
minds and their attitudes
about a certain
population after having
had a personal experience
interacting with them.
And what we have found is
that some companies come to us
and say, we don't want to do
any of this employee engagement.
Show us talent.
And we've actually
measured how many times
we present a candidate
to how many times
they, then, interview
a candidate presented.
And we've, then, later gone
on to have employee engagement
with that company and measured
the present-to-interview ratio
and see enormous growth in
once we have employee
engagement, meaning,
their employees or are
interacting with our job
seekers in a meaningful way.
MIKE DIAMOND: One last
question before we open it up.
And I think one of
the amazing things
has been watching
Upwardly Global's growth
over the past 10-plus
years, just in terms
of the amount of
job seekers they've
supported from
hundreds to thousands
in an individual year.
I know that you've
done a lot of thinking
about how to scale the program
beyond that contact-specific
piece.
NIKKI CICERANI: Sure.
MIKE DIAMOND: How
have you done that?
And with a Google
audience, we always
think about bringing our
product to a wider audience.
So how have you done that?
NIKKI CICERANI: Yeah, great.
We did as any 21st century
company is doing it.
We used to more technology.
So a program that was started
out being very much in person
with training-- we
realized we have
a population that is very
inclined to use technology.
They are highly skilled
in their home countries.
Anywhere between 30% and 40%
of them, in any given year,
have a master's or
better that work with us.
And so we didn't have to
do trainings in person.
We could absolutely use
the best of online learning
and the best of technology.
So we've really tried
to take everything
we were doing that we knew
were critical elements
of the program and do as much
of what didn't need a human
to do through
automation, technology,
robust platforms, and robust
online learning management
functionality--
I mean, to the point
where we actually now--
we were spending hours of human
time taking foreign resumes
and making them look
like US resumes.
And now we just built
our resume builder tool.
It just pulls it into a US-style
format, like, drop the picture,
and then interactive
trainings that teach you
what information goes
where so that, at least,
you can compete for the job.
Our job is not to
get anybody a job.
It's to give them
the tools to compete
for the job, which I think
is very inherently American.
And we're now doing that
with a technology platform
and a portal that we
can license to partners
like the resettlement system.
So if you are IRC and you
have X number of organizations
on the ground,
some of those will
be receiving higher
volume of refugees
that are highly skilled.
But the system's
not really set up,
as we heard from
Sussan, to do that work.
But some of them are
coming ready to go, today.
The Iraqis have all been
educated in English.
They speak English very well
if they went to university.
They don't need, necessarily,
to take a survival job.
Some of them are
coming because they
served the US military forces.
They know US culture
relatively well.
So you can have
tools that, now, you
can just embed in the
existing system-- community
colleges, libraries, even the
federal workforce system is
really geared towards
helping people get really
low-skill work or
mid-skill work now.
You can actually offer
it through the system.
They license the portal,
they license the resources,
and we're scaling
our growth that way
through productizing
what we've done.
And I just want to say this--
keeping data on all
of it since day one.
So the most fun
part of what we do--
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: I
was going to say that.
NIKKI CICERANI:
--and that I'm really
excited about for the
future, is that it's
like these mini pathways for
those who come to the US.
And the more data you
have, the more time
you can help them avoid
pathways that didn't work.
A doctor who comes to
the US of a certain age,
with a certain background,
and a certain specialty
may have decision points
in their journey in the US.
Should they relicense
as a physician?
Should they find
an alternate degree
that may take less time
and fewer resources
and have a higher
degree of success?
And we're going to start
to have enough data to look
at where are they in the US--
where were they educated?
How long ago-- to give
them some analysis of what
are the best ways for
them to pathway back
into professional careers
that use their skills
and their experience.
And there, we are
doing a little test
with a Google big data product.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: I would say
the data that distinguishes
Upwardly Global is incredible,
and it's the only way
to counter those stories
that keep circulating.
I mean, I'm a huge
fan because of this.
I mean, it really
distinguishes Upwardly Global
from any other service provider
in this field, I think,
in this niche.
MIKE DIAMOND: Really
exciting stuff.
So I do want to open it
up for audience questions.
And feel free to
please come to the mic
because we are
recording this talk.
So we'll open it up to you guys.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
That was so great.
So my question is, do you
guys have a clear end goal
that you're trying to
achieve for any given refugee
or immigrant?
What would be
considered a success?
Would it be a success if,
say, this doctor who came over
became a lab tech?
Would it be only a success
if he was still working
in the medical profession?
Or maybe, would it be
considered a success
if maybe his kids eventually
went to a really great college
and eventually went
on to medical school?
How are you measuring
your progress?
NIKKI CICERANI: That's
a great question.
So we've thought about this
problem a number of ways.
And I'm sort of trained
with an economics brain,
so mine is like optimization.
When are we optimized?
We have decided,
as Upwardly Global,
that we're sort of in
a turn of the wheel
where our goal is at least
creating a high-quality system
of nonvulnerable support.
And that's a fancy
way of saying,
no matter where
you land in the US,
you should not be without a
resource that can support you,
understanding where
and how to rebuild
your professional career.
And so this is sort
of the phase we're in.
While we've done that, though,
and because of the data,
what we have is a large
body of information
on licensing and relicensing.
What are the barriers, who's
relicensing, how easily?
Because remember for professions
like doctors, dentists,
lawyers, civil engineers--
and it's governed by state.
It's not even a national policy
that, where you land in the US,
may predict the ease with
which you can relicense.
And so I think, for us,
this first turn of the wheel
is about getting what we have
into the system in a way that
is not vulnerable and
ubiquitous and to be
able to collect the data on it.
And the second turn
of the wheel would
be optimizing for
understanding the policies
around certification.
So who's getting jobs?
Who needs to recertify?
And if they are in in-demand
fields where certification
is necessary, what and
how is most helping them
obtain those certifications?
In some cases, it's
financial support.
They don't have the $800
to take a Coursera course.
Again, we're being supported by
Google to sort of fix that gap.
In some cases, it's a
little more sophisticated.
It's just simply a very long,
arduous process to recertify,
and there's not necessarily a
benefit to the recertification.
It's that the
professional bodies
that govern these industries
stand in the way--
so a very classic example--
not to throw the physician's
assistance under the bus--
but a doctor could easily
apply their training
in their home country to
become a physician assistant
in the US.
Where the four
years that somebody
with no medical training
would need could be shortened.
But the physician assistant
professional industry group
holds tight that none of that
previous medical training
or experience can apply towards
a physician assistant degree.
And there, hopefully,
over time, our data
will help, if there's a
movement in the advocacy world
to be pushing for the
relicensing barriers
to be lowered.
For me, it would be
that, wherever somebody
has a skill that can
contribute to the economy,
we're not letting an issue of
their ability to compete stand
in the way, and
we're not letting
an issue of financial resources
to obtain the proper licensing
stand in the way.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: If
I could just respond.
So I would responded
a little bit more
broadly about the
settlement, right?
It's also about integration.
And I can't emphasize
that enough.
So what Nikki's
addressing is something
much more as a systematic
response overall, right?
The resettlement agencies
may get some people certified
because some of the
volunteers or support groups
may have that extra
money to do this.
But she doesn't want it
to be something ad hoc.
She wants this to be something
systematic that people have.
But the arc, the trajectory that
the resettlement agencies have
is the long term,
which is, we've
seen refugees and immigrant
communities over a long term.
So I always say to
refugees, yesterday was bad,
today may be bad, but
tomorrow will be better.
It's that idea of the
improvement is gradual,
but it happens,
and they definitely
see it with their families.
But not letting people be
isolated is so critical.
Because America will
suffer if we make
people afraid and isolated.
And we're seeing that
in countries in Europe.
And the reason we don't
have those problems
is we have absorbed people
well for hundreds of years.
We shouldn't be afraid
of absorbing people.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
NIKKI CICERANI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I would guess that the more
time people spend languishing
in refugee camps,
probably the worse it
is for the eventual outcomes.
Is that something you've
seen from the evidence?
NIKKI CICERANI: Yeah.
Particularly the older they
are when their journey starts.
So young people do better.
We've seen young folks
complete university pre
or during, even, time
in a refugee camp,
and then come out.
And because they're
still young, companies
will take a chance on them.
Those-- our experience
and our data,
I'm talking-- you can
probably talk about the field,
in general.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: I'll let
him finish his question.
NIKKI CICERANI: --is
that we've seen,
the older they are when
they get in a refugee camp,
and the longer they stay
there, it is, indeed, harder
when they get out.
That's what we've experienced.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: Is
that the question?
Were you going to
add something else?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: So there
are more and more programs
overseas that we call
livelihoods programs.
People are so anxious,
even psychologically.
So imagine if you're in a--
not just a camp,
but even a city--
where you're just a
welfare recipient.
And you just want
to be in control
of your life and your family.
You want a chance at a skill,
at a job, at something.
And actually, Google supports
a lot of workforce livelihood
programs all around the world.
My organization,
even in a program
in Israel for minorities in that
country, has Google support.
But it's so important for
people, even psychologically,
to feel they have a
skill, to have a chance.
But the need is so much
greater than the resources
out there to give
people, either the skills
or the jobs that they need.
But you're right.
And adolescents are
particularly vulnerable, right?
Because they're growing
up in this vacuum.
And that's so scary
because idle adolescents,
even in our own homes,
aren't a good thing.
Can you imagine in that
kind of environment?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NIKKI CICERANI: Exactly right.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI:
Or young adults.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to say thank you
because your outlook on
this is very positive,
and it's a great
narrative, actually.
As somebody who's worked
with adolescent refugees,
it's pretty dire.
Obviously, there's
a lot that can
be done with data and technology
and the idea of building
resumes and all of
this, but I want
to touch a little
bit more, again,
on what you were
talking about in terms
of networking and stuff.
Because I feel like even
for people born here
and everything,
that's a huge issue.
And their getting jobs-- and if
you could go a little bit more
into the work that you do and,
potentially, the more work that
could be done in terms of
working with the refugees,
integrating, creating networking
opportunities for them.
Because you could be the
best qualified person
and have a Spic and
Span resume, and if you
don't know the right
people, it's just not
going to happen for you.
NIKKI CICERANI: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I'll talk
about two things there.
One is just teaching.
Again, the gap in the system
is helping newcomers understand
that networking is
necessary, that it's
a part of how we look
for jobs, and we do it
outside of our family or
our immediate community.
So in other cultures,
networking might happen,
but it might happen in
a little bit more of--
it's family or it's
immediate community.
So education is a
piece of the puzzle--
just that it's done, getting
people comfortable with doing
it with US expectations.
Two, is the use of LinkedIn
from an educational standpoint.
So again, we just do training
on how to use LinkedIn,
how to do your profile, how
to optimize your profile.
LinkedIn helps us with that.
I think the third about
networks is a little bit more
of a systematic too.
When we see, like, how are you
going to get people hooked in?
And so I think two things.
I think that there's
a systematic response,
and I think there's a
community or movement response.
The systematic
response would be,
wouldn't it be great if the
resettlement system could
get everybody a LinkedIn profile
as they're starting, right?
And I think that
the badging movement
might start to help similarly.
But in the same way, you
have to have communities
that are opening their arms
and saying, we're here to help.
It's got to be a community
or movement-type response.
And I actually do think
you see that response.
Companies were very engaged
after the refugee crisis here
and, in some cases,
internationally, about saying,
how can we help?
And I think that idea
that you're actually
extending a hand, specifically,
as social capital--
first, in helping them
understand what's expected,
but then, in extending
social capital.
And I know it's
exactly as you say.
It's not technology.
It is the part of
the work that still
has to be done because
it's values-based,
it's what we believe
is right to do,
and because we're acting as
communities that are being
compassionate as
well as thoughtful
about economic integration
and its benefits.
I don't know if you
want to add to that.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: So
tell me the emphasis
of your question again.
AUDIENCE: Just the idea
of how you can take this--
it's almost the most ephemeral
part of getting someone a job
in the US.
And you can't just figure--
there's no specific
process to it,
no matter how you try in terms
of networking and helping
people with jobs
that way, given,
so much success in terms
of hiring and all of that
is driven by that very element.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: So
I think maybe Nikki
was alluding to it when she
said the community response.
But living in New
York, you really
see these themes of
different communities
that have specific jobs.
So the superintendents are--
I don't want to
say these things--
but are from a
certain ethnic group.
Or the people who work in places
that might be in the gas places
are from--
so people talk to each other--
technology, social
media has helped.
WhatsApp really helps.
And organizations,
humanitarian organizations,
resettlement
agencies like IRC are
trying to work very hard in
using technology to really help
people in terms
of locating jobs,
helping people in many,
many creative ways.
But I think people really--
so the really neat things
is refugees and immigrants
are resourceful, and
they're so smart,
and they know how to
survive and succeed.
We just have to be careful that
they're not so afraid to be
here, right, and so that
they don't turn inward,
but that they go ahead and
embrace the challenges that
are out there.
I don't know if I answered
you, but I think that--
AUDIENCE: You did.
There's a whole other question
about empathy from the existing
communities here, but that's
for a huge dissertation.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI:
But I have to say,
again, I would say,
on the positive side--
so all the agencies
that do this work--
and definitely the
resettlement agencies,
but I'm guessing even the
agencies that go beyond
resettlement--
the amount of support
that the American people
gave with their hands and
feet in terms of volunteers
and with their pockets
in terms of money--
when the rhetoric is ramping
up, the support systems
for refugees really are amazing.
They're just not aware of it
because it doesn't get press.
They just keep hearing
all the bad stuff.
But in America, the protections,
the support systems--
it's incredible, the
goodwill of America
towards these
individuals, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I hope you're right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
NIKKI CICERANI: Hi.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Do you have hard
or soft on what employers
find are the challenges in
terms of considering refugees
or immigrants into bringing
them into their organizations?
And is that something that
you've been able to write down?
Or is that found in a
certain location, in terms
of what challenges,
on the employer side?
NIKKI CICERANI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And do you
have any particular--
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: You
start, and I'll--
NIKKI CICERANI: OK.
Sure.
Yeah.
And to your question
about hard or soft data,
it's been soft until now.
We just did the first
sort of official report.
Oliver Wyman, actually, did a
third-party report on it first.
That's embargoed for
a couple more weeks.
But I can give
you some headlines
to what we thought
was going to be there
and that we've heard
over the years.
One is that, it's very hard to
take an alternative candidate
and advocate for them.
There is risk involved
in that as an HR manager
and, even, sometimes
as an employee
who's advocating
for a candidate.
So that gap at the top of
the resume, that education--
there's no US professional
experience on their resume.
So making a case for that
candidate feels risky.
And in fact, one of
the things that we've
experimented with
significantly over the years
is pushing for contract
work and measuring
how much of our contract work
turns into full-time work
for our job seekers.
And so we've seen about a 69%
conversion rate over the years
from contract to full time.
And that's because people
perceive lower risk
with time-bound contract work.
And so that risk
perception is very high.
And getting somebody
who feels safe bringing
an alternative candidate in,
and making a case for them,
and probably who feels
safe failing at having
somebody fully integrate.
Then the practical challenge of
it, after that, I think really
has to do with acculturation
and mentorship.
So is there a culture of
mentorship within that company?
We've found where there's a
real culture of mentorship,
they do a lot better.
We've also found
that companies that
have a lot of internationally
trained people at the top
just--
the accent is not a problem.
The fact that
"their" and "there"
gets spelled wrong and
emails is not a problem--
like what may be--
my mother's an English teacher.
And even when I say confusing
"their" with "there,"
I'm like-- my
anxiety rises, right?
But you know, we work
with a major bank.
They're an international bank.
And they hire folks
like crazy, like crazy.
Because it's just not--
those things are different.
And the culture of mentorship
is very strong there.
I think on the true side,
communication and acculturation
is a long and, in some
cases, slow process.
And so, I think, where
we've seen employers tell us
they're struggling is
the job seeker is in,
but they're not doing
particularly well in advancing.
They're staying right there.
And so it's because
they don't understand
the nuance of managing up,
or they don't understand
the nuance of communications,
or because more communications
has to be done remotely.
And it's just not been
a long enough time,
or they're not coming
along fast enough.
And that's just a reality.
So part of, as we've
grown, what we've done
is to put more in our
resources for, both companies
and for the immigrants,
once they have their job.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK, great.
So there are resources for once
you've actually
confirmed [? that-- ?]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NIKKI CICERANI: Exactly.
Well, we've got
5,000 alumni now,
and we're adding them at
a clip about 1,000 a year.
And that's when we were
sort of like, uh-oh.
We have a new problem.
We've got alumni who have to
succeed in order to make way
for those coming in.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: I think some
of what Nikki talked about
is also true for American-born
people who are struggling
in these survival jobs.
I would just say, from a
resettlement perspective,
I think the mentoring
is very important.
But many resettlement
agencies try
to work with companies
or employers that
will accept a liaison
for a period to make
sure there aren't any problems.
And a lot of
employers would like
to have somebody to go to
and talk about these things.
And then you bring
in people who, maybe,
somebody who's wearing hijab or
somebody wants to go to pray.
And for these communities,
it's nice to have other people
from their parts of the
world at that same place
so that they're not
the only ones there.
But that's just--
AUDIENCE: Are there
resources to help set up
those liaisons between foreign
companies and stuff like that?
Or is that something
that companies
define for themselves?
How does that--
NIKKI CICERANI: We do that in
a very bespoke way right now.
As we've evolved our
model to be technology,
and they've all been scalable.
We focus, first, on the
job-seeker side of this,
and then we still
do custom stuff
like that with our companies.
Whereas, the second
turn of the wheel
is about enabling companies
to have a playbook
and/or resources that would
do training internally--
cross-cultural training
for those who are
going to play that liaise role.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI:
So the newcomers,
and refugees in particular,
the resettlement agency, very
often, will try to do this.
And also, the whole push
for, take your first job
so you have some record of
having that job showing up
to work, to us, is so important
in the beginning, right?
It's a very different place than
by the time Nikki may see them.
AUDIENCE: I guess this is
kind of related to what
you were just talking about.
When you were mentioning
the eight-page resume with
the details that an interviewer
cannot legally ask about.
It makes me wonder
because I am the child
of Italian immigrants.
And even now, I sometimes
have a difficult time
explaining to them how
certain things work here, even
as opposed to my previous job.
Google [AUDIO OUT] slow ramp
up in comparison [AUDIO OUT]
other software firms that
I've worked for in the past.
So my question is,
how difficult is it
to teach the job seekers how
different American customs,
regarding employment are,
and how difficult is it
for that information
to be retained?
I'm not sure how
else to explain it.
SUSSAN KHOZOURI: [INAUDIBLE]
NIKKI CICERANI: Yeah.
Well, adults are
experiential learners.
And so when we say we try to
make as much available online
that they can be self-paced in
and use the time that we have
with the humans that we have
to raise money for and pay--
to practice.
And in fact, many of the
things that we practice
are the things that
feel unnatural.
So like you said, Italians--
and I'm speaking as one--
if we were coming over from
Italy, perhaps the ways
in which we would
approach a job search,
we would have to turn
some things down,
amp some things up, and
those are the things
that we spend time practicing.
Because we found-- and it
is largely documented--
that adults learn by doing.
So we did a lot of
information sharing
through online learning.
We spend a lot of our
in-person human resource
time on the practice in order
to ingrain those behaviors.
And in fact, we
continue to try to use,
and are looking
forward to using,
more technology that gives
positive feedback when
the right behaviors
are demonstrated.
So when you say,
how hard is it, it
does also become a
very individual thing.
I've seen 67-year-old
engineers come to us
and just decide they get
it, and they're gonna do it,
and they have a job quickly.
And I've seen a
30-year-old Iraqi man--
you know, just-- he's
not in this space.
He's-- usually, a refugee,
and they're struggling.
They're struggling
with acculturation,
it's not their
moment, and I've seen
them take a very long
time in the program.
They're simply not
ready yet to accept
that this is the way it
is or something like that.
So I would hate to make
generalizations based on age.
I tend to think it's about where
we meet people in there journey
or in their process.
But that, it is always,
for me, what I've seen
is practice and time on task
for adults yields results.
AUDIENCE: And then
when you say that,
but also talking about
these automated tools that
you're building like the
résumé builder, like--
somebody gives on a résumé their
religious affiliation on it,
you have to say, you can't have
that on an American résumé.
And that's different,
because now,
you're not really doing anything
personal with them directly.
How do you deal
with that scenario?
NIKKI CICERANI: [? Best of ?]
online learning is my response
and then an advisor.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NIKKI CICERANI: Like,
online learning--
it's interactive.
They see a person come on,
and they say, look, in the US,
we tend not to share
personal information.
This is what a US
résumé would look like.
And then, we have a help line.
So if somebody's not
progressing in their training,
we get a notification
they've stopped.
We then use part of
our help-line capacity
to understand why
they've stopped.
And if it's that, again,
they're not trusting,
they need to hear a human
voice for a second--
we've had that happen.
I had somebody who--
he told me, he's
like, you guys don't know
what you're talking about.
I even remember his summary.
He wrote-- and I don't
know where it went wrong
in the translation, but his lead
in was, I'm an awkward leader.
And I tried desperately
to say, the picture has
got to come off, and awkward--
I think we're going for
a different word here.
And he didn't get a response
from the job market.
And he came back a couple
of weeks later, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I can relate to that.
Thank you.
MIKE DIAMOND: So are
there any more questions?
If not-- I just want thank you.
[? Thank you ?] for coming.
[APPLAUSE]